peu et
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu fais là
pourquoi veux tu que je te fasse du mal
aller là bas ma tante a fait cuire je te
connais pas tu étais venu de là ou à
pied j'étais placé depuis trois mois et
qu'est ce que tu peux la gauche est dans
merde alors il ya encore pas si je peux
faire quelque chose pour toi deal tu as
fait j'ai rien te donner moi mais je
sais bien mais quand même si avec moi
quelques mois la garde c'est la musique
reggae
voilà où nous en sommes s'appelle pas de
bruit sinon machine à boire et
bien des saints prochain
pas si sûr étrangers la paille tu aimais
généfique de taden qui sèche sur les
caddies cela puis c'est ta durée zelda
capitole j'étais sur une autre chose au
jeu face jean rien
[Applaudissements]
c
[Musique]
dans les pages et bien peu de
socialistes ne s'en aperçoive je dirais
que j'ai fournis dans la rame dans tout
ce temps ah oui c'est ma faveur de la
vie et quitter la maison je vais pas
porter de verre de bordeaux
imaginez nous avons su profiter d'un
voisin pour une fois dans bienvenue à
pois c'est et au ghana
bah oui si tu te saoule à quoi tu
comprends rien à ton âge tu va réveiller
this town bastia ça va et qu'est-ce que
tu t'imagines je vais te saouler pour tv
nt1 un pauvre petit j'ai assez de femmes
dans ma vie je n'ai pas besoin de toi à
moi ce que je peux ainsi souhaité de te
dis moi tu t'appelles pas m'écouter mois
paralysant les matins je me cherchais du
charbon avec la charrette jusqu'à ma
cabane à de grandes capes
je voudrais que moi je t'appellerai
singer je n'oublie pas de fermer la
porte avec le gros bateau anne parce que
les renards essayé de virer en brasse et
cette nuit et à leurs yeux c'est pas la
flamme de la bougie qu'il est généreux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
histoire de me tuer je t'ai entendu
rentrer et sortir je me demandais ce qui
t'arrive et moi je les fais n'y
j'imagine que des morceaux qui a brûlé
ouais mais ils sont durs à forcer un je
les ai eus
ça serait pas la peine a déposé la fille
aux riches ne pas profiter la session
bonne femme a voulu je me vois ce que je
voudrais te dire qu'elle est à mon goût
salé trop sèche 80
ma mère disait toujours ce et les femmes
qui font et défont les maisons ou mais
n'était pas bête atteint hier à l'aise
ou un âne hormis les jours
[Musique]
est-ce à sortir si sûr car il ya guère
que les écureuils pour s'occuper de nos
affaires ni arrivée ces amours là bas
c'est pas ma femme allaitant jets ont
bien pour ceux qui vivaient là dans le
temps parce que bon la fin ça veut dire
obama fait vers la cabane à la cera de
monde pareil le charbonnier nadj et dj
auquel brûle chez nous tu sais la
provençale et bien hadji encore en salle
ça veut dire y'en a pas mon pagne
il termine à toutes ses conversations
par des choses de ce genre
la justice honnête j'ai les baveux genre
léger alors on a fini par lui donner ce
faisant à la place des vrais avis
au pis toi tu es là tu vas mal à des
filles maintenant c'est une petite
écurie pascaline j'ai trouvé deux fois
ci commence à approcher la demoiselle
venez voir le café il est bon malgré que
nous ce soir face au paris vous savez
chez nous le luxe dachier aller boire un
café à cotonou dans l'histoire d'abord
faut que tu nous expliques que nous tu
viens parce que nous tue c'est les
filles qui roule
ouais les filles qui roule nous les
aimons guerre et pour les femmes il faut
faire pourquoi t'es chiant parce que au
jour de maintenance d'honneur j'ai des
femmes lagière nagy 1 8i une énergie
libre si pour le garder mon honneur que
je suis parti la nuit sur les routes
toutes les filles sont pas comme ça nous
nous demandons qu'à te croire
avec almatois venez d'où exactement car
j'étais trouver mais j'étais classé chez
monsieur hier le juge au tribunal de
commerce
oui j'avais connu madame hubert chez
nous elle était très malade alors on
avait envoyé prendre de bonne heure ce à
quoi tu étais déjà servi non j'habitais
une ferme avec ma mère et mon frère
allait nous étions heureux tous les
trois puis mon frère et s'est fiancée
avec la suzanne via un mode sur léman
puis c'était au pacage qu'à la fin de
tout la 6ème et s'est marié avec jean
baptiste et ce magot qui était mon
premier au port alors pour que les voir
ensemble je suis parti avec madame
hubert selma les mots qu'il ya deux mois
je suis resté seul avec monsieur hubert
tous les jours je voulais partir et tous
les jours il me demandait de rester et
pourquoi tu voulais partir
ce n'était pas bien
la préversion de sa femme lui avait ôté
la raison les plus ré il se mettait à
mes genoux
toutes les nuits il voulait venir dans
ma chambre quant à sa juge veuve par
dessus le marché
tu sais un juge ou pas juge bafoue paref
devant un bon morceau thurman a
d'appétit
mais toi tu voulais rien savoir
ça te disais rien jugeait même avec elle
en robe noire et je vous ai déjà dit que
ce n'était pas une fille comme ça ba et
la fin comment ça s'est passé
la fin c'était avant hier il s'est jeté
sur moi j'ai poussé des cris pire qu'une
bête
il me disait des choses que la décence
dépens du mans poste au tir heureusement
que sup les fortes crues je les jetais
de toutes mes forces contre on a comme
moi d'ailleurs il s'est fait mal en
retombant
je veux dire que ses fans lui le canon
mais il avait l'oreille instant dommage
ça méritait mieux mais j'ai mis dehors
il n'avait plus de résistance il restait
encore une heure à ma porte en
m'appelant il en approuve sa femme il
vous appeler toutes les deux pourquoi
faire ça fait fermer la porte et est
poussé la commode de saint capraise moi
je me suis sauvée alors j'ai marché j'ai
marché au petit matin j'étais tellement
fatigué que je me suis arrêté pour
dormir passe hélas vous m'avez trouvé
et dans ta tête qu'est-ce que tu
comptais faire m'a retourné en savoie
seulement la bahia jean baptiste ici
ouais tu préfère pas y aller quoi
pascaline
c'est pascal emond oui je reste avec un
nom pareil
pourquoi j'aime mariette et le sait mon
père était avec nous à la gamme
maintenant il veut plus dit que les
nobles on doit les laisser tranquille je
suis les pères du gard ou de l'année
j'aime bien de l'islam et moi ça
m'ennuie de le savoir cinq compagnies
alors je me suis pas c'est que peut-être
sekera beau ici pour une jeunesse mais
je mettrais dans l'or dans cette perle
de le mettre à celui paroles de femmes
et en plus elle est à dire un peu la
charbonnière que la fin du mois je te
donnerai scène prend comme ça tu pourras
tu acheter des robes laissant je te
trouve bien prétentieuse est-ce que tu
espérais cette nuit gaffe d'éprouver
dans la foi c'est qu'un point c'est bien
s agenouiller devant toi pour que tu
épouses ça tu peux pas te le dira
comment est ce que je fais c'est pour
toi m je dois photo sha l'apparent on
ndjana onana devant elle est battue sera
pas mal à résister aux maladies et c'est
un brave homme et le temps de l'europe
je viens de vous dire bonjour
qu'est-ce que tu espérais de tenues
ayant été prouvé dans le fossé qu'en
pensez vous s'agenouiller devant toi
pour que tu les pouces ça te plait pas
tu veux dire
moi ce que je fais c'est pour toi je
t'offre d'oshawa parents on ndiagne en
lainage ça te va elle est battue sera
pas mal à résister à la 17ème brave
homme et le temps à autre je viens de
vous dire bonjour c'est toujours vous
dire
il
marié quand ça veut dire qu'ils font à
la maison des viguier parce que moi j'ai
plus de merde alors là tu te crois que
ce sera une belle note thérèse hostile a
priori pas peur a gagné des sous dans le
commerce layton alors les plus éclatants
au élevé puis sera partout
bah
je m'en vais là tu viens dépendre les
sacs ce soir surtout le pas la grande
là je vais à tous ceux qui marchent pas
ils à toulouse quelqu'un me sens
complètement pipeau toujours voici les
grandes villes le bateau il ya le port
et surtout vérifier que pas froid aux
yeux
la déco porte à athènes au centre ça se
voit elle a divorcé
voilà qui règle la ici pour se soigner
ses réserves pour soigner la garde et à
toulon la belle a victory pour me
soigner moi tu vois ses efforts pour
régler les choses car on l'aura only
[Musique]
et je
ce
aux filles est déjà clair il faut bien
qu'on mette relance est heureuse et tout
ça viège 8e fermait les rigueurs du code
forestier inquiète la population
il ne peut vivre au moyen de ses propos
toujours armé de son fusil le berger
fait reculer le garde
il vient de se rendre lorsqu'il faut
mais des listings dans la forêt vous que
les gars voulaient me dire ce qu'ils
font quand même à l'héberger dans la
forêt il suffit qu'ils cuisent leur
dîner sur un petit feu pour qu'on les
accuse de saint-dié l'estérel te
deschamps souhaitait pas plus urgent
d'étudier ce qui a marqué sur la journée
à la cour voici raconte ça je suis
content on peut pas savoir lire aux deux
mois dit roberto mois
nicolas est celui qui compta louis mais
le mot paix en moins il a vu que dès la
sortie des trois millions contre la
donne
il semblait s'arracher les tripes à ce
qui se dit les églises sont tellement
avare qui se rapproche le pain qui
marche tant mieux comme sainte-thérèse
ne gaspille pas les soins quotidiens
et puis je vous de voir cerrone by par
un café au bar et à brignoles
ils veulent taxer levens comme moi dans
les chats noirs et ce sont les
carpentier qui pousse le chamois et qui
sortent quelque sorte de club à la mode
anglaise n'ont jamais payé le droit
louis philippe lui éviterait ne brouille
avec l'apparition en attaque alors
libertés privées est ce que nous sommes
en tournée je vais te poser quand même
peyras o fils et je vous écoute tu étais
responsable 1 3 me le braquage vient de
se donner et me rendrai hommage bien mal
tu veux relever et à guirane et plein de
télévision
pour petit froid que tu accueilles du
raisin et des cerises pour retrouver tes
sous la condition été récoltés soit
bonne passe au gel
la sécheresse le patron voulait revenir
à ceux ci il n'y a qu'une valeur sur
l'or tu le mets bien à l'abri dans un
coffre d'année solide à la maison tu
t'en vas tu peux plus ils feront appel à
ses valeurs
c'est cool et maggie rentrer les jours
mais plus ma terre j'attends que les
vignes tourisme et le tout donne le ton
domaine à bail ménagers et étudier tests
allaient ici avaient châtié à que
thérèse vous aurez la moitié de la
maison et vous livrer tranquille ça
souci je vous demande aux mille pardons
et thérèse voulez vous faire une
maîtresse de ferme est pas une dame de
ville
vous exagérez un peu beaucoup monsieur
lozès tournon vous vous entêtez à ne pas
comprendre mais il ya pire que la
sécheresse et la grêle ya les guerres
j'ai connu la misère des paysans au
début du siècle ont maintenant quand on
parle napoléon les jeunes à ils font les
yeux rome il a dans la langue totaux
goff rivoli va gras austerlitz des
pyramides ils vous disent les français
il était partout et veulent jeter
partout les princesses abbas il était
partout les français n'étaient pas chez
eux mais il y avait plus personne pour
planter les poires il plongea de la
vigne si demain à casser un bruyant qui
nous pouvait on entendre de nouveau la
guerre qui la fera qui la fera toujours
les paysages et ça recommencera l'année
que les pièces d'or écoutez monsieur le
guen napoléon louis philippe à la guerre
ou la paix moi je m'en fou ce que je
veux c'est faire prospérer maggie
rendent l attente de votre fille et
servir à ça et pas autre chose vous avez
compris au bout des hawks est long et
bras m'en tombent
c'est presque fini tu seras magnifique
l'absout m'intéresse
tamarii j'espère dit on dirait que ça te
fait pas plaisir de te marier demain
puis ça approche
ça me met dans les transes et pourquoi
mon petit il faut pas affoler ta
grand-mère haute et un témoin on est
toutes passées par là on se fait une
montagne puis c'est pas terrible
il ya même eu des femmes à qui
s'applique à faire alors le contrat est
signé
j'ai versé l'argent mais laurent pseu le
garder pour lui le changera au pied de
vigne fumier en confort et en lapin pas
moyen de lui faire entendre raison
kin two dit c'est toi je lui ai même
parlé de napoléon mais des pyramides a
de plus il ne veut pas s'installer ici
il m'a dit que depuis la mort de sa
pauvre mère tout allait à l'abandon chez
lui et qu'il fallait une femme pour
tenir sa maison qu'est ce qu'ils croient
que thérèse et va lui servir de bonnes
fées se l'imaginent il aura la grosse
déception
c'était des gands c'est merci refleurit
guillaume il avait apporté un lot à
michel belgique
le père de laurent c'est un bien de
famille c'était bien ça va chez nous
personne n'a jamais été un s'érige pour
la peau tennis de par son mariage il
aura peut-être y arriver ses
beaux-parents mais ayez pour en
déshérence et laura lui mais il portera
le dire se munir de l'avis de la
puissance alors la bataille abu dhabi
qui leur donne moi ton beau costume
je termine et que le pagne là plutôt
artistes hearn a dit préparez des
vibrantes portait alors pareil ça va ça
peut pas mieux aller ça tu vois là et
construire le rapport la langue gratuits
et puis les écuries s'il est bien géré
et offert ayant avec ama consolidée dès
que la ville commencera à donner il nous
faudrait un kubota fois plus grosses
tout ça ça va coûter beaucoup plus cher
que les 3000 fans de la date de sortie
qui sonne elle nous a gâtés alors qu'il
faut un bal widor elle sait tout faire
un fils toi tu m'as fait un beau cadeau
un mauvais achat c'est que j'ai été à
quelques jours de me marier parce que ça
fait très mal et moi j'aimerais bien
gardé ici je crois pas que sa mère et
est offert à plus de rentes pas non plus
c'est pour ça que je peux laisser un
commentaire
devrait aller recevoir les invités il y
en a déjà plein la cour et je file à
bord de compter les sons comme donneur
ajouté tu crois vraiment qu'il faut
jeter ou tout c'est avec la du mariage
de leur fille comme juge de la
respectabilité débarras tueur et son
buste
moi j'ai toujours réseau allons-y
apparaît dépêche toi qu'on est en retard
le covan ce sale toi oui
[Musique]
apparaît dépêche-toi connaissant encore
de quoi faire
le pire est comme un jeu sa toile google
[Musique]
ce
ceux ci
des petits je suis parti avant la fin
les chars et les danses se plus de mon
âge je t'ai porter un bout de gâteau et
quelques dragées regarde toi tu sais moi
les réjouissances
ça me dit guerre c'est plutôt pour le
fiston lui les potins alors moi aussi
dès qu'un jeu les vues installé dans ses
idées j'ai dix jours au monde
je vote parce que la petite elle est
toute seule là où il faudrait pas
qu'elle ait peur mais si vous êtes je
suis remonté aussi parce que je me sens
mieux ici que dans leur vallée je suis
un vieux samedi et pme que sa sauvagerie
mais une jeunesse comme toi peux pas
comprendre tu n'as pas encore idée de
travail l'a pas encore là ça devient
dans chaque poubelle prouve chaque abuse
lcd mois après la déception de l'exam
bâtissons que nagy
[Musique]
madame michèle il fait jour il fait
felipe soif
baladin michel bonjour ma balle car il
est d'ailleurs de se lever pour
descendre à la cuisine des coûts journée
pour nous ce dimanche et oui mais le
dimache hommage autant les autres en
jour ah ben je risquais ma mère me
servais mon les deux pôles au lit tous
les matins faux gentils et à this town
qu'elle me le prépare après le meurtre
bon ben je descends
ap tokyo et la voilà et le tessin
d'apple corps s'en faut et coop lsi
fatigué que ça doit sa place mais j'ai
été et je me suis levé la première ans
pour servir mon homme on sait que le
premier jour de classe habite à thème
dans l'ue à préparer sans les deux
poules oui je vais le mettre au garde
manger pour qui ce qu'elle n'offrait pas
plutôt le reporter sportif ou alors dans
son lit bah oui quoi la voile a demandé
où jamais ta grand mère se serait fait
servir d'insomnie alors pour demander ça
il faut être un article de la mort
tu vas pas me redonner une chose
pareille tu veux pas non à toi je
permettrai pas écoutent leurs hommes
tempère avaient tous les défauts de la
terre et même un bon pain supplée marin
mais servir sa femme ça il l'a jamais
fait c'est même le seul reproche qu'on
pourra pas lui adresser
donc je te le donne pas je préfère lui
porter moi même le biberon à cette
princesse leur appui voilà la vie n'a
fait des petits humains paquet open
r je vienne et puis et puis à l'épée
quoi et bien c'est tout lui va jeter
toutes les cannes et son tour des
carottes mais celui d'yves on attend
foutu
[Musique]
laurent laurent leurs mollets de poule
en bas quoi sur la table en bas oh
paradis
l'aréna j
par analogie
et puis apparaît vous ne l'entendiez pas
un souper près d' qu'est ce que vous
avez
je me sens fatigué c'est un plan de de
coopi cette petite après tout d'un coup
j'ai pu me parlait pas je ne veux pas me
quand même coup de froid et vous avez
mal à tes deux barges le chômage je vais
faire une bonne tisane et puis vous vous
mettrez - allez l'appuyer vous sur moi
et à l'heure des restes tu es là bas
ok bonheur et tu pensé que ça pourrait
être au nom encore cette fois cours rien
que trois mois qu'on est marié
la femme de toute classe a été créé sur
le mois qui a suivi cette offre est
celle d'un camion gastinel aussi et j'en
connais qui sont aller encore plus vite
elles ont commencé leur petit avant de
se marier arrêtons-nous discuter quitte
on a besoin de toi il ya les petits pois
les clients la belge ancienne je suis
jamais allé quérir avec les valets sauf
pour un musette que tu mets plein de
gens s'y intéressent
fiona qui rendent chez nous chez toi tu
commences à comprendre
[Musique]
et le dessin à la vieille halle a fait
pas travailler quand même à la balle
ovale
les petits pieds alors le coaster ça
continue je finirai pas quoi je suis
devenu remue les bras pas mais les
petits pistolets jusqu'à 9 heures le
jour où elle est enceinte elle me passe
à l'inaf m'a couché
oui y'a des jours chez les soigner comme
j'ai pu mais pas mieux ce matin je me
suis affolé il parle tout seul j'ai vu
ça par exemple tu as bien fait de venir
attends moi je montais faty à terme a
gagné en 10 tonnes naji est malade à la
fille est venue me polony est à petit il
gouverne les porcs allait
this town qu'est-ce qui se passe
le parrain est malade la fille qui le
gardaient venu avertir vous descendez
dames 11 ans au petit pois je suis
fatigué allez-y avec le valais et il est
occupé
il a les cochons à renvoyer eh bien nous
irons devant le maître sera pas content
d'eux qu'on vous mêlez-vous je paye les
domestiques avec l'argent de mon père
pour faire le travail et pas pour qu'on
me fasse faire est mort d'êtres de
facilité à oublier que je suis née
demoiselle est qu'ici je suis la
patronne
j'ai toujours vu que la patronne était
celle qui travaille et le plus pour nous
qui est posée argent épouse de faim je
finirai par quoi colo m a fait une bien
mauvaise affaire en exposant une riche
l'appareil je te sens mieux oui tu peux
me lâcher petit je me taisais this town
ça me fait du bien de voir la viande ça
va
thérèse thérèse c'est un épisode qui ont
poussé à la ville quant à l'europe elle
dans la campagne là là en plus c'est
difficile le v6 petit renne mais bon
pour patienter
dubois fiston toujours paddle d'un pitch
en l1 j'ai fini par croire que ce plan
allait faire des pantins ça avec intérêt
ça n'a pas l'air d'être l'alléluia et il
faut dire c'est une fille à qui j'aurais
j'avais passé si elle n'est pas eu
d'argent au bout parce que pour le
travail intéressant c'est pas un poids
qu'elle est dynamique s'est donné que
nos chemins ça tu pourrais pas le
prévoir là alors elle se nomme plus
penser que de jouer un jour devenir plus
qu'un round
vous finirez par s'aimer comme ben marie
une bonne femme
les canaris thérèse nagy et des voix
mais pas l'envié de retourner à toulon
valenciennes à victory est serré mais je
me méfie toujours des japonais et des
femmes et la langue et qui remuent avec
les ligues et ça risquerait dr duguay
sais que j'ai encore besoin d'eux mais
je croyais que tu avais touché toute la
taute la date avec toutes les
réparations que j'ai eu à faire et qui a
restauré
c'est tout à l'heure je vais passer par
des jeunes c'est par la pop est un bon
amant faisait en a besoin
[Musique]